[Music]
our first speaker is Denis let me
cha-cha my honor to you one of my first
graduate students at MIT and Daniela is
a professor in UCSD and he is really the
world authority on lattices and lattice
cryptography and I also wrote one of the
first may be the first book about this
right what's your thesis about lattice
Kapaa graphene lattice based algorithms
and the nearly made the very appropriate
commented before lunch we had quantum
cryptography and he's going to talk
about post quantum cryptography which is
quite appropriate and again we have a
real treat in front of us so it's fun so
I'll be talking about a lot of these
problems and zero knowledge and this
I'll be talking about latinus and zero
knowledge so let me start with a brief
introduction to both the things
so lattices lucky this our mathematical
object that we're at first there was
that had been studied by mathematicians
they for white a long time they started
being used for the construction of the
cryptographic functions starting in the
mid 90s after a discovery of aitai that
there is a connection between the worst
case complexity of lattice problems and
average-case complexity in average case
is what you need in cryptography so that
you get hard to break functions when you
get your key chosen at random while
worst case complexity is a much weaker
assumption that you can try to study and
understand without having to worry about
distributions on how the problems are
representing so this opened up the
possibility of building cryptographic
functions from certain types of the
worst case assumptions which also
happened to be potential
candidates it for across quantum
cryptography mean the determine post
quantum cryptography didn't exist yet
back then but the short algorithm was
already there so people already knew
that that kind of public key
cryptography being used and still being
used was subjected to quantum attacks
and lattices offered a possibility to
design a quantum proof classical crypto
system something that can be used with
just regular recombinant classical
computers that is not wrong to be
breakable by one to my algorithms
another another discovery that got
attention to these problems was that
proof that SVP the shorter spectral
problem which are which I remember to
define is np-hard the standard the
notion of
harness used in complexity theory and so
this opened up the possibility of try to
base the cryptography on the minimal
assumption that P is different from NP
and retake after between what you need
for cryptography and what can be proved
NP completeness of both problems use
approximate versions of SVT of the
suspected problem and there is a gap
between the factors for which one can
prove MP completeness and the factors
which are required for cryptographic
functions and understanding this God was
one of the motivations of some early
work on interactive proof systems and
zero knowledge proof systems for lattice
the problems now they're your lattice
cryptography substantially expanded the
after the introduction of the learning
with errors problem by rag and then a
few years later the proposal of the
first fully homomorphic encryption
scheme based on lattice problem problems
and today lattices lattice cryptography
is considered one of the main candidates
for post quantum cryptography so on to
lattices what is a lot is a lot is a
domain
object is a set of points in Euclidean
space it's something similar to a vector
space you can be described by a basis
for example in two dimension you may
give these two vectors to B 1 and B 2
and instead of taking all the real
linear combinations of the basis vectors
you take only linear combinations with
integer coefficients so the result is a
discrete set of points you get only the
intersection points of this grid for
example this point is a B 1 plus a 3 B 2
you can take B 2 three times and then
add the b1 to it and the same lattice
can be described by different bases so
this red base is saying the picture is a
basis for the same lattice defined by
the blue basis and the complexity of
solving a lattice problem depends on
which basis you are given if you're
given a shorter basis points become
easier if I give you if I give you a
longer basis a basis with long vectors
so for the same lattice then the basis
has bad geometric properties and that's
the source of computational hardness now
there are two main problems that are
studied in this area one is called the
Saurus vector problem
you are given a lattice to describe body
by a basis and you want to find that the
shortest nonzero vector in the lattice
which as you can see in this picture is
not necessarily one of the two basis
vectors so you may have to take some
combination of the basis vectors to find
that the vector with a smallest possible
length and another problem is the
closest vector problem is EBP where you
are also given a target point K and you
want to find at the point in the lattice
which is as close as possible to the
target now most of what I'm going to
talk about today applies both to the
shortest vector problem and the closest
vector problem but for brevity I will be
talking only about this one about the
closest vector problem so if you're
interested in the shortest vector
problem you can find something similar
ring paper okay so these are the two
problem sir so let's move on to the
other ingredient of my talk proof
systems and you already heard from
Thomas so that GM
you grab the tree call or eNOS I'll
discard actually only there and only the
problem here or not the root system so
there's a program a very far is the
probe system is a matter before it ruler
to show to the verifier that a certain
statement is valid for example the
statement may be that this graph is 3
colorable you can call out all the notes
with one of three possible red colors in
such a way that any two nodes which are
connected by an edge have different
colors and the simplest way to prove it
is to release the coloring you can tell
to the verifier
how to color each node but in at zero
knowledge proof system and you can try
to hide the coloring you can convince
the verify that the graph is 3 colorable
but without revealing the coloring so
this is an interactive process where the
prover and the verifier exchange
messages messages that are chosen at
random at least by the very tire at the
end of which the very buyer knows that
the graph is 3 colorable but as no
information whatsoever about the dead 3
coloring so what I want to talk about is
proof systems for lattice problems and
so this is interesting for various
reasons one historically proof systems
have been useful to understand the
complexity of problems or computational
problems in general they played an
important role in the development of
computational complexity and they also
had many direct applications in
cryptography especially zero knowledge
proof systems a for example they can be
used to design identification schemes
they can be used for proofs of plaintext
knowledge when you want to reveal you
want to convince somebody that you know
how to decrypt a message but without
giving out the decryption and they can
be used in secure computation and group
signatures anonymous credential systems
and many more
so so my plan is to talk so the stock
will be focused mostly on the early
worker in zero knowledge of all
realities problems which gives a nice
setting to explain the main ideas that
are also found in many other subsequent
constructions so what we will do is that
to talk about the very first approach
system for relative problems that was
designed by God triangle buzzer ringing
mm and and then move into some other
another proof system of myself in Baden
where we addressed some efficiency
issues that are important for
applications so the first worker was
motivated by complexity issues
understanding the complexity of the
lattice problems and this other second
proof system was motivated by developing
at least the theoretical applications
where you could use the pro system in an
actual protocol and something that is
important in that same thing is to have
an efficient way to implement the proper
strategy which is not something that is
part of the basic definition of a proof
system so I will sketch how to use these
proof system to build a zero knowledge
identification schemes and proof of of
plain text knowledge and at the very end
very very briefly I will mention some of
the recent work there has been really a
lot of work in the last year or so on
zero knowledge proof system support
lattices motivated in part by all the
applications of the zero knowledge in
various areas and there's really a lot
of there are many developments going on
which for the pretty much in two
categories one is a design in zero
knowledge through systems for lattice
problems so you have a problem about
lattices you want to prove something
about lattices for example if you
encrypt something using lattice base the
encryption scheme then you may want to
prove that you know the underlying
plaintext and there are also zero
knowledge proof systems where you use
lattice assumptions to prove arbitrary
statements
not necessarily about lattice problems
in critical you may wanted to give a
zero knowledge proof system for any
statement in MP that can be implemented
efficiently so so first of all so these
Gigi gold record Vassar reproach system
is it was motivated by this gap between
the factors so for which we know how to
prove that lattice prongs are NP hard
and those required by cryptographic
applications in particular cryptographic
applications require the
inapproximability hardness of
approximation for polynomial
approximation factors for Inman in what
in the dimension of the lattice in the
picture I was only showing
two-dimensional lattices but for
security the dimension of the lattice is
the security parameter ram so in
practice and you typically work with
lattices in dimension that is a few
hundreds like two hundred three hundred
up to a few thousand as depending on the
application and NP hardness results are
way far from there they're all force a
polynomial factors in affected typically
this factor is just a constant the
constant independent of the dimension so
the question was is value is there any
hope to push these NP hardness results
for factors that I read potentially
useful for cryptographic applications
and there was already some result of
this type for example if you can show
that lattice problems for a certain
approximation factor are in the
intersection of NP and Co MP then they
are unlikely to be np-hard
because that would collapse NP n Co MP
to the same complexity a classic but the
factors for those results were at least
linear in the dimension of the lattice
which is pretty much what we can use to
build the cryptographic functions and so
Shafi I know that Godric is so they came
up with a negative answer to the
can we prove NP hardness results for
factors that are as large as and in fact
they gave evidence that there is no NP
hardness result for factors that grow
with a square root of that dimension in
order to depth they put to these
problems as we PNC repeat in the
complexity class as the case that is the
got zero knowledge which we know is
unlikely to contain np-hard problems
under standard the complexity
assumptions okay so how does this prove
system may work so I tried to keep by
most of the talk with pictures
explaining and the concept with teachers
I am now very simply fine a number of
issues but I hope that the pictures give
the main ideas that so let's say that
you had a lattice and let define the set
of black points here in the picture
defined by a basis and you're also given
a target point ax T and you want to
prove it that this target point is far
away from the lattice so how can you do
that so it is not clear how to do it in
a non interactive way how to write down
an NP proof in fact we believe that
there is no empty proof for this
language when the approximation factor
is small enough short short proof yes
yeah so there are not short proofs okay
proofs that you can write down then read
and check so you can try to go beyond
this barrier by using interactional
random method and you can proceed as
follows first you take this target T and
you copied all over by the sheets that
are defined by the lattice so you
consider the set T plus ended a shifted
copy of the nut is where the shift is
given by the target then you can see
there are two possibilities so the
verifier is going to flip a random coin
and decide that to either choose the set
of lattice points so the red points you
the picture or that set of shifted
lattice points where the lattice points
are shifted by the target tip so once
the verifier
makes this random pick then it will
choose a point that is either closer to
the first set of points so anywhere in
these circles in these red circles in
the picture or it will choose a point
which is close which is inside the blue
circle so it will decide that to be
either here or there and then it choose
a point that is close to one of these
two collections of points it says this
point to the Provera
and the prover is to guess if this point
was picked from the red circles or from
the blue circles if the prover can come
up with the right guess then the
verifier will take it as evidence that P
is far away from the lattice and I will
illustrate in a moment why that provides
some evidence now it's clear that the
verify the program can always guess this
bit with probability 1/2 so for these
two provide substantial evidence you
need to repeat this approach system a
number of time so you may repeat it to
say 100 times after which you know that
except with probability 2 to the minus
100 that the point is indeed the far
away from the lab so what makes a
disprove system work now so these that
the to see questions so in one case the
shifted copy of the lattice is done with
a shift which is far away from the
lattice and it is the case then the red
circles and the blue circles are
disjoint so when you pick a point from
one of the circles so they prove a given
unlimited computational power assume
that the prover is all-powerful they
prove it in check for example by
exhaustive search if it came from a red
circle or a blue circle them on the
other hand if there's not a case if the
target point is close to the lattice
then the blue circles and the right
circles will have a substantial overlap
they will have a big intersection so if
the verifier
a point from one of these circles with
high probability will be from the
intersection of the two circles of the
two lists so the plural will have no way
to determine if the verifier started
from a red circle or from a blue circle
and that what makes the proof system
correct and sound correct when the
target is from the far from the lattice
they prove enough information to
determine where at the Challenger
pointer came from while in the other
case soundness if it is not far if it is
close to the lattice there is a big
overlap now an interesting observation
is that this proof system is also zero
knowledge and it is zero knowledge
because the verifier is just getting
back his random vector so when we're in
this world the verifier picks a random
bit B and C that the prover knows the
bit as a verifier already knew to start
with so it's not really learning
anything new okay so there are some
efficiency issues so this is a useful to
establish that the problem is in this
complexity class statistical zero
knowledge so it is unlikely to be
np-hard however if you want to use it in
cryptographic applications so this
doesn't quite give so there are several
efficiency issues that need to be solved
the one which is a very simple one is
that I said that the tiger is speaking a
random lattice point and then adding
some noise to eat and then that is an
infinite object so how what does it mean
to pick a random lattice point
so of course you cannot pick it from the
entire lattice uniformly at random now
the way this was originally solved it
was by taking a big ball or a big cube
containing many lattice points and
approximating the entire lattice with a
finite subset but it is there is a
simpler way to address this random peak
in a problem which became a pretty much
standard in lattice cryptography and
this interactive proof system is one of
the first settings where District
going to describe it was used so another
efficiency issue is that each time you
repeat this protocol the verifier is
only getting one bit that is only
getting one bit of confidence that the
point is far from the lattice so it
needs to be repeated many times so is
there a way to design better proof
systems where you executed only ones and
the verifier knows with high probability
that your point is either close or far
from the lattice and the last one is
that proven in this proof system and
needs to figure out to eat the target
comes from the red or blue circle if
it's close to the lattice or close to
the target but that's exactly CBP the
closest vector problem a problem which
we believe is hard so it's something
that requires lot of effort to solve so
I'll go over these three points in the
sequence and so how to address them so
the first one is this issue of what does
it mean to pick a point at random and so
you can do something completely
different instead of picking a point at
random what you do is to look at the
displacement of a perturb lattice point
inside the DES fundamental region and
defined by the lattice so you can think
of cut in your space into cells and then
put pins taking up of this piece of
paper one on top of the other and just
looking at the displacement of your
error vector within the fundamental
region of the lattice so this is the
effect of forgetting which lattice point
you story from so it is perfectly
equivalent to starting from a completely
random lattice point and so so this map
pinger so you can define just a
deterministic function and it takes a
small error vector and reduces it the
model of the lattice that is it takes
only the displacement of this point
inside the fundamental that cell now if
the set of lattice is the this under you
can do for any lattice if you take the
specific family of random lattices that
it was used by I tie two
prove average-case harness you get a
very nice way to describe this function
so i guys lattices where they find not
by a random basis but by a random
wording : theory is called the parity
check matrix so the lattice is defined
by a random matrix a with entries that
are integers modulo Q and the lattice is
the set of solutions of integer
solutions to the system of equations ax
equals 0 modulo Q so it the set of
solutions is a lattice you can also
compute at bases if you want but most
applications don't need that there is an
entry there is a useful correspondence
that reducing that point an arbitrary
point X which may not be in the lattice
reducing it the modulo de la this is
exactly the same as computing a matrix
vector multiplication if you compute a X
modulo Q this will be 0 if X belongs to
the lattice and nonzero if X is not in
the lattice so so this gives a nice
convenient way to compute a one-way
function based on the closest vector
problem now I so this picture is a bit
misleading it is not quite iodized
functional you can consider two versions
of this function depending on how
depending on how big X is now if X is so
if the error vector the input is not
enough that when you reduce a model of
the lattice the result is always
different so if the function is still
the injective then so this is a learning
with error problem introduced by ragged
in 2005 and I could I tie it could prove
harness of these problems only when the
error vector was large large enough that
when you reduce your input model actus
or when you multiply your vector X by a
you end up covering potentially every
point in the fundamental region of the
lattice so in this case you have a
surjective function so the function is
essentially the same is it is the same
problem and but for two different values
of the parameters of the error large
error or smaller error and the fact that
here the function is surjective and here
is injective enables different classes
of applications so there are many more
applications based on injective
functions for example encryption can
more easily be built from injective
functions so let me mention a few
cryptographic primitives that can be
built pretty much in a direct way from
this function from this simple lattice
vector multiplication so give a sense of
how that is cryptography works so you
can build the collision resistant hash
function so this function not only is
one way not only is harder to invert but
is even hard to find collisions between
two different input so here you would be
using ITEX version of the hash function
which is surjective it compresses the
input and it was observed by a sharpie
Godric and Halevi that you can also
prove that finding collisions is hard
and that's already a much more useful
cryptographic function than just a
one-way function so another simple
application is commitment schemes and so
you can think of a commitment scheme as
a randomized version of the hash
function you append some randomness to
the input to X is the value that you
want to commit to you attend some
randomness to it and then you hash it
using your function a and so this
commitment scheme was proposed and used
to design a certain type of zero
knowledge proof system by
Karachi Tanaka ago in 2008 I will
describe the proof system in a few
slides and encryption is very similar to
commitments so the way luck is based the
encryption works it's almost the same
you can think of commitments as
encryption without the decryption
algorithm in what cases you want to hide
the message and the encryption algorithm
is the same it's only the decryption
which is missing here and so in this
setting you can formulate the problem of
proving knowledge of the decryption of a
message or the message underline a
commitment so and prove in that you know
that message X underlined a certain
commitment is exactly the problem of
proving the knowledge of a solution of a
system of equations of the form ax
equals y which is exactly the a parity
check reformulation of the closest
vector problem so all of these reduces
to giving a proof system so possibly
zero knowledge proof systems for the
versions of the closest vector problem
okay proper efficiency prover efficiency
is critical to use the proof system in
an application so you can run the
approval on a computer and so the idea
is so the GG proof system didn't have
efficient rotors and most likely there
is no way to make the prover efficient
so in order to get through the
efficiency you need to come out with a
different approved system perhaps for a
not exactly the same problem so what you
can do is the same is the following
instead of proving that T is far away
from the lactis let's say you want to
prove that T is close to the lattice and
now that the statement is is that the
opposite the proving it is close to the
lattice you may assume that the prover
knows the lattice point close to T and
this lattice point close to T is the
word plays the role of a secret key in a
cryptographic application and that's
what will make the computation easier
for the prover
then for the verifier and achieve
security in the cryptographic
applications
another question is can you come up with
a proof system to show that that T is
close to deadly but without revealing W
you want to prove in zero knowledge that
T so T and L and the lattice are known
this would be a public key or a publicly
known commitment and you want to prove
knowledge of the lattice point closer to
it
so so this is direct applications in
identification schemes and many other
simple applications I mentioned before
right so you could use these apparel at
this basis B and a target t as your
public key they'll at this point close
to the target is your secret key and you
can put that is the public key on a
server reddit uses that as your identity
in order to identify yourself to the
server you prove knowledge of a lot is
going to close to T and if this is
indeed a heart his distance of the
closest vector problem you will be able
to read to do that but other parties
that don't know your secret kid or not a
lattice point close to the target will
be in a hard position to prove that
statement rather if the proof system
that you use to show knowledge of a
nearby lattice point is zero knowledge
then an adversary that observes the
exchange of messages or even an
adversary that is impersonating that
server and is talking to the prover red
will not learn anything from the
interaction so your key will stay secret
and the adversary will not be able to
impersonate you even after observing the
interaction okay so let's get it to the
second proof system so so this is a
probe season to show that a target the Y
is closer to the lapis and it works
roughly as follows so again we pick
other points as close to we pick both
points that are closer to the lattice
and points that are closer to the target
and since we are going to reduce them a
model of the lapis you don't need to
copy the target many many times you can
simply reduce this point and bring all
of them inside the fundamental region so
the verifier will solve the prover will
pick say two key points
half of them are from B and half of them
are from around Y and
the very fire will send a challenge bit
so this time it is the verify the very
higher reveals the B before it was kept
secret and approval minute to guess it
and verify are essentially is asking to
the prover to show that the adder the
number of lattice points in the red
sphere and green sphere is even or both
numbers are odd the sum of these two
numbers add up to 2k we have a total of
two K numbers so we'll have the eight so
the number of points that are closer to
one or the other point will be either
both even or they will be bought
although these numbers and they prove
their claim so that these two numbers so
can both be even at the same time or odd
at the same time which is only possible
if there is a point in the intersection
of the two spheres modalities but the
only way for the two spheres to
intersect is for the target to be close
to the lattice so being able to answer
both questions are shown so the only way
to be able to answer both questions is
that the lattice point is close to the
lattice so I hope this is sort of game
with intuitive idea so I'll describe now
a different way to present these two
troop systems but described at a
different level of abstraction in terms
of commitments so commitments I will
already describe the number of time so
today is a night order to take a message
inside an envelope you can seal it the
commitment is to properties a secrecy
property that says that when the
envelope is closed the you you cannot
tell that what's inside so if you're
putting in meetings and these envelopes
you cannot tell if the bit is 0 or 1 but
at the same time the commitment is
binding once you close the envelope
there is no way to change the message
bit which is inside it now the closest
vector problem and a spread before gives
a very special type of commitment which
is both perfectly binding and perfectly
hiding which is not possible in general
you cannot achieve both properties at
the same time but you can achieve them
in the following sense
so think of these two sets of
also remember the red circles and blue
circles of course these he implemented
the using reduction model or delicous
but it's very easier to visualize so
think of the tweaking a point from the
red circles as a commitment to zero
while picking a point from the blue
circles as a commitment to one so these
are the way you committed to zero into
one and now notice if the target point
is far away from the lofty this
commitment is binding because the blue
and red circles are disjoint so
commitments to zero and commitment to
one are completely different on the
other hand if the lattice point is close
to the lactis the commitment scheme is
hiding so the circles overlap in the
limit if the target belongs to the
lattice the circles are the same so the
commitment scheme mat will hide the beat
because commitments to zero red circles
and blue circles are essentially the
same distribution unperturbed points so
you have these discordant instance
dependent commitment because the details
of how you computing the commitment
value it depends on the CDP Easton's
that you are given you are given a
lattice any target point and then
depending whether it is an instance
where the target is close to the lattice
or far from the lattice the property of
the commitment are different now
so we know that these two properties
hold the true it will be hiding yeah it
depends if you are thinking about your
proof system or microbe system ok so you
can describe with both of systems in
terms of this commitment function and so
in your proof system what you are doing
is exactly picking a random bit then
committing to the random bit sending it
to the prover and approvers to guess
which bit it was so it is to break the
hiding property and by breaking the
hiding property it is showing that the
target point is far away from the
lattice because when it is close to the
lattice the commitment is hiding okay
while in
the proof system with efficient provers
so the you are sending a commitment to
zero they prove that is sending a
commitment to zero here I am
oversimplifying considering a single
message rather than 2k so you can think
of a sending a commitment to zero or
just any fixed commitment and then the
verify RS to the prover to either open
it to zero or to open it to one and the
prover will be able to answer both
questions only if it can break the
binding property of the commitment
scheme so in this case by breaking the
binding property by showing that you can
answer both questions you are showing
that the target point is close to the
lattice so traffic which of the two
where you of these two things where you
systems are zero knowledge okay so you
are using the same underlying instance
dependent commitment that based on the
closest vector problem and you get the
different properties that can be useful
for different purposes there is one last
issue that is so this still even today a
gap for certain type of efficient proof
systems from lattices so there is a gap
between what you need to know to show
that a point is close to the lattice and
what you are proving to the verifier so
in the previous proof system so this is
tougher this should have been a EPI
so the so you're showing that this point
P is a close to the lattice and it is
also closer to a shifted copy of the
lattice in what cases could be within
distance better now by triangle
inequality it follows the distance
between T and the lattice is at most
twice better moreover in order to get a
zero knowledge property beta is to be
quite a bit bigger than the distance
between TN and it has to be bigger
roughly by a factor square root of n so
the brooder needs to know a point within
a certain distance X and it is only
proving that the lattice point the
target is within a distance bigger than
that by some a factor so there is this
knowledge gap between what the prover
knows and what the prover is able to
show he knows that has an impact on the
practical concrete efficiency of zero
knowledge proof system so reducing this
gap is useful that now there is a way to
reduce this gap and this what was the
first done for a variant of CBP by
kabocha tanaka in segawa is the paper i
mentioned before where they suggested to
use lattices to build the commitment
schemes and what they did in that work
was to do adapt a previous zero
knowledge proof system for coding
problems that was suggested by Jacque
Stern some 10 years earlier and they
showed it can be adapted to certain
versions of lattice problems in
particular consider a lattice problem
where the error is a 0 1 vector which is
perfectly balanced it has half a 0
entries and half 1 entries and the proof
system works by the prover committing to
three different messages that are built
from a random permutation is a
permutation of the coordinates of your
vectors and a random vector R which is
given as an alternative secret is not
the error vector that you want to prove
is the shorter is a randomly chosen
value are they
it also convinced it to a permutation of
our and commits it to a permutation of X
plus R now there's a little bit
technical but if you just the work on it
if you any two of these messages do not
reveal anything about X I mean it is
clear that these two don't reveal
anything about X because X does not even
appear there but if you look at this two
for example they also hide X because
from this tool all you can recover is
that permute a pepper muted version of X
and since X is a balanced vector with
half zeroes and 1/2 ones when you take a
random permutation of it you get
something which is completely
uncorrelated with X is a uniformly
random error vector from that set of
balanced binary vectors so this was
useful already for some applications but
if you think of it in terms of lattice
problems you would like to solve this
problem for short vectors and not
vectors vectors which are bound to
satisfy this a constraint so you would
like vectors that belong to a ball or a
two-door cube or some other regular
geometric structure and so this
something was achieved by laying the yin
Stella and one a few years later which
showed essentially how to reduce the
problem for the L infinity norm and so
if you want to show that all the
coordinates of the error are at most
better so you can take this problem and
turn it into one that can solve the
using that tkx protocol I showed a
moment ago so there a proof system that
was introducing again a knowledge gap
but it was a factor too between what the
prover knows and what the prover is a
show in to know but that can be easily
added so it can be easily removed so
there's a variant of this proof system
suggested by M stands for myself and it
so any work to do so this variant that
works as follows so you want to show
that all the coordinates of X are at
most beta that is there in the interval
minus beta
- better so first that you can shift it
to be all positive but by adding better
to all of them now you want to shore it
all the numbers are between 0 & 2 beta
plus actually we're at a plus 1 so it
would be only the two beta here there
are two beta plus 1 possible values and
then you can try to write all the
numbers between 0 & 2 beta you can find
a collection of numbers alpha 1 to alpha
2 K is such that all the numbers between
0 & 2 beta can be written as a subset
sum of these numbers and not only as a
balance to subset sum it has exactly K
elements equal to 1 and K elements equal
to 0 so this is very easy to do when
beta is a power of 2 you just take the
powersoft when you write the binary the
composition of your numbers and at this
point you just want to show knowledge of
a binary balance vector which can be
done using the previous protocol so I'll
quickly for okay good thanks
so so there is another class of
protocols zero-knowledge protocols that
addresses the issue of knowledge error
so the protocols I showed before so this
one the where III possible so this one
so the very fire was asking to open two
out of these three commitments so every
time you execute it there is only a
constant probability that it will catch
that proved error treating so you need
to repeat it a large number of times now
there is a different type of protocols
which follows the approach of the snore
identification scheme and that if you
were at the other workshop yesterday was
described by Dan Boneh so so that one
was for discrete log base proof system
and there is a way to adapt it to
lattices and so you want to show
knowledge of a vector exit to a solution
of ax equals one and you can do that by
sending a are for a randomly chosen
error and when you receive a challenges
C from the receiver you reveal a random
combination of X and error and since now
see can come from a large set a
potentially exponentially large sector
and the prover can only answer one of
these queries without the statement
being true it will immediately achieve
soundness error which is one of the
possible choices for the vector for the
challenge C
however this proof system introduces
again a type of knowledge gap because so
the sound is the rest on these two
properties assume that the prover can
answer two challenges a C Prime and C
double prime and it can give you short
vectors X Prime and X double prime
satisfying these two a questions now you
can combine them together and you get a
small solution to the system ax equals
not quite Y but equals C Y for some
constant C so the prover is showing not
knowledge of a pre-image of Y it is
showing knowledge of the preimage of a
multiple of Y and in this discrete log
setting you can just divide everything
by C in the lattice setting where you
also want numbers to be small you can
you cannot do that if you do division
modulo Q numbers from small that can
become very big so you cannot quite do
that now this proof system was used as
the basis of a number of digital
signature schemes
starting from day one time digital
senior scheme of myself and noobish is
key and one property of the scheme is
that it didn't require random Oracle so
so was standard the security but it only
allowed to sign one message now if you
replace the fixed query with a random
Oracle that you can get the schemes that
can sign an arbitrary number of messages
which can also be a
improved and optimized in various ways
and this is this technique called the
Fiat shanira with a burst that was used
to design a sequence of more and more
efficient the lattice based dissimilar
skins some of which are some of the
candidates to the current and needs the
post quantum cryptography
standardization process so I just slide
it where I'm just mentioning the some
recent results one of them is about to
use in lattices to design a
non-interactive zero knowledge proof
systems and this was first done in a
2008 for lattice problems so this is
something that's been known for a long
while and the question was can you give
lattice base proof systems and not just
for lattice problems but for arbitrary
problems in NP and there were some
various types of partial results giving
solutions that are not quite a
non-interactive zero knowledge but they
are restricted forms of zero knowledge
and this problem just got solved very
recently months ago by Teichert
insertion that gave a non-interactive
zero knowledge problem from the standard
l.w assumption for all of MP building on
some recent previous work of the
connecti and others that already had a
framework with some more complex
assumption and it was turned into a
standard a lattice of W assumption and
so there is much more recent work that I
don't at the time and to talk about but
just to give you a sense this is a
sample of papers on lattice zero
knowledge from this last year giving a
zero knowledge resistance for specific
problems methods to achieve a sub linear
complexity and properties for arbitrary
arithmetic circuits something which i
think is very interesting is this work
of the opinion rubenesque aware what I
do is to prove properties all the
lattice base the crypto systems but
using a discrete log assumptions and
they make an argument that even if you
if you want the post quantum security
so this system is achieving statistical
zero knowledge and it is achieving
soundness and are a quantum assumptions
the Sundanese is something you check
right away during the introductory in
the interaction so even as long as
quantum computers have not been built
yet you can use it and if somebody
stores all the interaction to break it
when quantum computers are built well
there is nothing to learn from data
because the system is a statistical zero
knowledge so it's a nice combination of
the two techniques which could
properties that are are interactive you
need to break it right away I mean it's
you cannot postpone the interaction
later on of course for non interactive
zero knowledge it is different but yeah
so the for the interactive version of
the protocols you don't need the post
quantum security until it is right yeah
yeah it binds you by Gemara there are
other properties that you get from
interaction you can get forms of
deniability and methods that to avoid
the proofs being transferred by
interaction is not always negative it
can also be a useful future right and
this concludes my talk thank you for ice
[Applause]
any questions okay so we move on and now